bien
monsieur le
monsieur le Premier ministre mes chers
collègues
nous avons été informés le 19 octobre
dernier que le Président de la
République envisageait de nommer sur
proposition de la première ministre
monsieur Jean Castex le poste de
président directeur général de la Régie
autonome des transports parisiens la
RATP en application du cinquième alinéa
de l'article 13 de la Constitution
comme vous le savez cette nomination ne
peut intervenir qu'après l'audition de
la personne pressentie devant les
commissions compétentes commission
compétentes de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat il y a encore du larsen
Audi
j'ai donc voilà je vais
c'est pas moi
audition qui est bien entendu doivent
être suivis d'un vote
cette audition est publique et elle est
ouverte à la presse
à son issue nous procéderons un vote
pour lequel il ne peut y avoir de
délégation de vote la commission de du
Développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire de
l'Assemblée nationale vous entendra
demain matin et c'est à l'issue de cette
deuxième édition que nous procéderons au
dépouillement simultané de ce scrutin
avec celui de l'Assemblée nationale
je vous rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 13 de la Constitution il ne
pourrait être procédé à cette nomination
si l'addition des votes négatifs de
chaque commission représentait au moins
3/5 des suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions ce rappel est enfin nous
souhaiterions vous entendre Monsieur le
Premier Ministre les objectifs que vous
souhaiteriez poursuivre si nous donnions
notre aval à votre candidature vous êtes
récemment déjà prêté à cet exercice
puisque nous vous avions avec nos
collègues députés donnaient un avis
favorable à votre candidature à la
présidence du conseil d'administration
de l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport de France
Lafitte à la fin du mois de juillet
dernier
naturellement cette nouvelle candidature
qui intervient trois mois après cette
première nomination à la tête de Lafitte
nous interroge aussi et dans ce contexte
assez inédit pourriez-vous nous exposer
les raisons qui motivent votre
candidature à la RATP je vais sans
attendre passer la parole à notre
rapporteur Philippe Tabaro qui va
conduire bien entendu cette audition
vous pourrez ensuite présenter votre
candidature et nous faire part de vos
motivations avant de répondre aux
premières questions du rapporteur et à
l'issue de ce premier échange mes
collègues sénateurs vous interrogeront à
leur tour pour une séance de questions
réponses je passe immédiatement la
parole à Philippe Tabarro
avec le même micro président
monsieur le Premier ministre mais mes
chers collègues c'est un plaisir avec le
président aujourd'hui pour cette
audition il faut bien l'avouer nous ne
pensions pas vous retrouver si
rapidement pour étudier votre
candidature à une nouvelle nomination si
cette audition est une audition
d'exigence j'ai souhaité mener un
travail préparatoire afin que notre
échange soit le plus éclairant possible
et qu'il ne soit perçu ni comme une
formalité convenue ni comme une tribune
inquisitrice
pour cela et pour la bonne information
de mes collègues sachez que j'ai échangé
avec la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse avec
Didier Migaud présidente de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique avec Catherine Guillouard
ancienne présidente qui a récemment mis
fin à sa fonction pour raison
personnelle mais qui avec détermination
à préparer le groupe à l'ouverture à la
concurrence et mener à bien de nombreux
chantiers
la question centrale de cette audition
est la suivante
l'ancien premier ministre Jean Castex
peut-il être le nouveau PDG de la RATP
sans nul doute votre appétence et votre
compétence sur les transports sont au
rendez-vous comme nous l'avions déjà
exprimé très largement en juillet
dernier je peux en témoigner en tant
qu'administrateur de la fuite l'Agence
de financement des infrastructures de
transport que vous présidez ou président
dès vos premiers jours à la tête de
cette agence j'ai pu constater une
impulsion nouvelle une mobilisation
accrue des services de l'État et un
nombre record de conventions signés et
de crédit consommé
j'y voyais un atout et le renforcement
du plaidoyer en faveur des transports
alors que suis-je ce sujet a été
totalement
occulté durant la présidentielle par la
grande majorité des candidats d'ailleurs
et qu'il revient à la boomerang dans
l'actualité pour autant ce premier point
positif est grippé par un chapelet de
réserve et de remarques que l'on ne peut
camoufler premièrement votre nomination
vient semer à une longue liste de
recazage s'apparente en moins au mérite
qu'à la loyauté votre expérience risque
injustement et je dis bien injustement
de se confondre avec les autres
nominations d'Emmanuel Macron celle des
naufragés du suffrage universel des ex
ministres ou proches de la première
première dame qu'il soit nommé à la Cour
des comptes à la préfecture de police de
Paris au Conseil constitutionnel au port
et aux Mucem de Marseille à la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie à
l'IGAS ou au comité de la biodiversité
les Français ou mieux le président de la
République lui-même n'en voulait plus
ils les ont fait sortir par la grande
porte de la démocratie il a trouvé le
moyen de les faire rentrer par les
fenêtres du copinage c'est donc cela le
Nouveau Monde
deuxième point nous sommes pour le moins
surpris de vous retrouver si rapidement
après vous avoir questionné pour votre
nomination à la fitte le 27 juillet
dernier 104 jours seulement sépare le
Jean Castex qui se présentait devant
nous comme le candidat de Lafitte
candidat plébiscité de celui qui se
présente aujourd'hui comme candidat à la
direction de la RATP nous espérons que
cette dernière candidature sera la bonne
et si vous resterez et que vous restez
pas ouvert à d'autres opportunités de
nomination que nous aurions à traiter et
puis quid du devenir de la fit
dernier point nous avons été fortement
embarrassés par les réserves de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique à première vue son avis du 18
octobre dernier
qui a été cité par le président Longeot
semblait contraire à ces strictement le
plus possible exercice de vos futurs
fonctions vous demandant de vous
abstenir de toutes démarches auprès des
membres du gouvernement qui était en
exercice lorsque vous étiez Premier
ministre ou encore jusqu'au 16 mai 2025
auprès des services qui étaient placés
sous votre autorité quel dirigeant d'un
établissement public de transport aussi
important que la RATP peut s'abstenir de
tout contact avec le ministre des
transports ou le ministre de l'Intérieur
mais mon entretien avec le président de
la Haute Autorité a permis de mieux
éclairer et écarter les questions
pénales et déontologiques de ces
réserves dans le cas de spécifique de
l'ouverture à la concurrence vous devez
simplement vous abstenir de démarcher
c'est-à-dire selon la définition du
Larousse de mener à bien une entreprise
telle une intervention faite auprès
d'une autorité en l'occurrence auprès de
vos anciens collègues ministres la
frontière me semblait poreuse mais le
président Migaud a levé mes doutes
le cadre de cette nomination est à ainsi
poser je souhaitais bien sûr vous
interroger sur deux sujets qui me
paraissent cruciaux et mes collègues le
feront sur d'autres sujets bien sûr le
financement du transport public en
France et votre stratégie à la tête de
la RATP pour ce qui est du financement
du transport public je sais que vous
avez conscience de la situation de crise
que nous vivons des infrastructures et
du matériel vieillissant des autorités
organisatrices de mobilité à l'agonie
financière à l'image d'Île-de-France
mobilité qui n'aura pour seule solution
aux grandes dames de sa présidence que
de baisser encore son offre ou
d'augmenter fortement son passe Navigo à
contresens de la décarbonation des
transports que nous appelons de nos vœux
comment trouver de nouvelles ressources
en investissements et en fonctionnant
comme cela avait été promis par votre
prédécesseur à Matignon qui ne sont
jamais arrivés comment ainsi rétablir un
service de qualité à un coup acceptable
après une dégradation palpable depuis la
rentrée pour ce qui est de la stratégie
du groupe allez vous continuer la
politique de la présidente billard qui a
essayé d'aller chercher des bénéfices
dans d'autres pays ouvert d'autres corps
de métiers que le transport public pur
pour lutter contre la perte probable du
de marché en Île-de-France du fait de
l'ouverture
de l'ouverture à la concurrence
automatique et de la sèchement des
subventions publiques où allez-vous vous
recentrer sur le corps de métier qui est
le transport public et notamment
l'Île-de-France enfin le président de
l'aide RATP Jean Castex sera-t-il celui
qui défendra les mesures de sécurité
portée par l'entreprise alors que le
gouvernement que vous dirigeait il y a
peu les refuser quelquefois à travers
ces ministres de l'Intérieur au travers
d'amendements sénatoriaux comme celui
qui visait par exemple à supprimer
l'obligation de reclassement en cas
d'avis d'incompatibilité rendu pour
occuper une fonction sensible notamment
pour les fichiers S pour conclure en
fonction bien sûr de cette audition et
des réponses que vous apporterez à nos
questions comme je l'ai dit pour moi
compétences et appétence demeure la
priorité des priorités aussi à titre
personnel et sans engager ni mes
collègues ni mon groupe je voterai pour
votre nomination fonction de PDG de la
RATP je le fais dans un seul but celui
de ne pas vous affaiblir au moment où
juste après le départ de Catherine
Gillouard et avant une grève qui vous
est offerte comme cadeau de bienvenue le
climat social et l'offre de transport se
dégrade et le marché concurrentiel
s'active fortement je crois que nous
avons tous plutôt intérêt à ce que vous
réussissiez cette grande est belle
mission et ainsi éviter le déclassement
du Groupe RATP de ses 69000 salariés sur
un plan régional national et
international je vous remercie de votre
attention
mais merci monsieur le rapporteur pour
ses propos qui ont mérite de la clarté
monsieur Premier ministre vous avez la
merci beaucoup monsieur président
monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs d'abord
même si c'est dans des circonstances
particulières c'est un plaisir de me
retrouver devant vous je n'aspire pas à
changer de poste
tous les trois mois rassurez-vous mais
et je vais vous en expliquer les raisons
je suis heureux de me retrouver devant
vous en tant que postulant à la
présidence du conseil d'administration
en direction générale de la RATP très
très belle entreprise vous savez toutes
et tous de notre patrimoine national qui
est confronté vous l'avez dit monsieur
le rapporteur nous allons y revenir
beaucoup de difficultés
mais ça n'est pas fait pour me
décourager alors chers Président vous
dites pourquoi pourquoi vous revenez
devant nous alors que effectivement je
j'étais pas dans la même pièce mais
devant la même commission à la fin du
mois de juillet pour la présidence de
l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport
dire tout simplement pour les autres que
vous avez vous-même rappelé à ce
moment-là la RATP n'était pas vacante et
personne en tout cas certainement pas
votre serviteur n'imaginer qu'elles le
deviendrait c'est d'ailleurs l'occasion
pour moi si vous le voyez bien de rendre
hommage non seulement comme vous avez je
vous en remercie commencez de faire
l'action de Catherine Lillois qui a été
une une présente extrêmement engagée qui
a affronté toutes ces difficultés avec
beaucoup de courage
qui a fait évoluer la RATP et qui a
engagé toute une série de chantiers
qu'il faudra j'y reviendrai poursuivre
et qui a fait vous le savez toutes et
tous ici c'est un choix personnel
à sa vie familiale que je trouve tout à
fait remarquable et honorable
il m'a permis bien entendu de le
commenter en tout cas qui explique que
elle a annoncé je pense un peu à la
surprise générale au début du mois de
septembre donc postérieurement à
l'audition à laquelle vous allez faire
qu'elle allait quitter ses fonctions je
crois à l'échéance de du premier octobre
suivant bon
si bien que je lui dis sans détour et en
toute transparence la commission lorsque
pour exécutif en place ma demandé si
cette fonction m'intéressait je vous le
dis vraiment j'ai répondu spontanément
positivement
alors vous dites est-ce que ce sera la
bonne ce sénateur bon c'est pas que la
précédente c'était mauvaise
j'ai essayé enfin je veux dire j'étais
très heureux de présider l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport je vous remercie d'ailleurs
sur les appréciations puisque nous yions
ensemble que vous avez bien voulu porter
sur les quelques semaines que j'ai pu
accomplir il y a beaucoup à faire
peut-être on y reviendra puisque vous
l'avez évoqué bon mais c'est pas tout à
fait la même la même dimension ai-je
besoin de rappeler aux membres de la
commission si je devais donner
simplement de comparaison ou de choses
ça veut pas dire grand chose enfin quand
même la fift c'est malheureusement
d'ailleurs cher sénateur 5 agents
bon là il y en a alors même si j'ai bien
compris avec les parts de marché qui ont
été conquises dans les premiers appels
d'offres hors du périmètre historique de
la RATP on a dépassé le seuil des 70 000
salariés bon c'est pas tout à fait le
même enjeu et le même le même chalet bon
en revanche me semble-t-il je pense
qu'il y a de ma part une cohérence
cette cohérence je n'y reviens pas
puisque
j'avais longuement insisté devant vous
lors de la première édition c'est je
crois beaucoup aux transports aux
transports collectif ce sont des Ageux
d'avenir fondamentaux pour notre pays
qui sont à la croisée d'abord de je vais
y venir dans un instant de la très
quotidien pour des millions de nos
concitoyens de vie de tous les jours vie
de tous les jours bien entendu des
enjeux de
de structuration et d'aménagement du
territoire en l'espèce de territoire
francilien même si
le rapporteur l'a rappelé la RATP à
l'initiative des précédents présidents
et notamment de Catherine Guillois s'est
développée or des frontières non
seulement de l'Île-de-France mais même
du pays
et développe son savoir-faire qui est
grand en la matière et puis bien entendu
ai-je besoin d'insister devant cette
commission des enjeux de le
développement durable de transition
écologique qui sont fondamentaux et sur
lesquels je voudrais si vous motorisez
redire bon voilà on va dire tout
simplement comment les les choses se
sont passées
il y a beaucoup de défis c'est difficile
ben oui oui je ne les sous-estime pas du
tout je vais venir mais bon vous
commencez un peu à me connaître c'est
pas fait pour me décourager si j'osais
devant vous je dirais même que ça
m’aiguillonne
donc
je suis fier d'être devant vous
postulant à ce à la direction de cette
entreprise
éminente dans notre paysage troisième je
vous le rappelle opérateur mondial de
transport urbain
très lié à l'histoire de la ville
capitale et qui est en plus confronté
aujourd'hui à des défis extrêmement
lourds extrêmement considérable et qui
en plus en pour caractéristique de se
présenter devant elle c'est-à-dire
devant le pays
dans des échéances extrêmement
rapprochées
vous les avez dit mais je voudrais
revenir pour
vous je le dis tout de suite je suis
candidat à la fonction je ne connais
encore pas tout de la RATP j'ai encore
beaucoup à prendre je le dis devant les
collaborateurs de cette entreprise qui
sont là mais
l'expérience et la vision qui sont les
miennes me conduisent à vous dire bon
d'abord qu'il va falloir s'occuper des
filles de très court terme
vous l'avez souligné la presse ça me
fait l'écho permanent il y a un sujet de
qualité de continuité du service très
fort qui a marqué ou qui marque encore
bien sûr le service des bus avec vous le
savez près d'un quart de l'offre qui n'a
pas été réalisé
au mois de octobre et on voit aussi
des difficultés dans le métro en tout
cas sur un certain nombre de lignes j'ai
pas besoin de développer vous l'avez
tous vu voire peut-être comme l'usager
que je suis
expérimenté bon
bon pour autant enfin on va revenir les
causes les difficultés de recrutement
des problèmes d'absente de gestion des
Ressources Humaines je voudrais pas non
plus je le dis vous comprenez dans la
fonction qu'elle a bien aujourd'hui et
dans celle que je projette qu'on tombe
dans le RATP bashing que je sache
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs s'il n'y
avait que la RATP qui avait des
difficultés recrutées je parle surtout
vos territoires et dans tous les
secteurs professionnels ça saurait sauf
que là ça se voit tout de suite beaucoup
plus
donc en tout cas c'est un sujet
d'actualité il y a toute une série de
solutions qui ont été ou préconisées ou
déployés soit par l'entreprise elle-même
soit par
Île-de-France mobilité la présence
Pécresse
allusion s'est exprimée et donc voilà
c'est le premier sujet là qui est sur la
table mais encore une fois qui rappelle
que la RATP n'est pas une île
que ces difficultés de recrutement elle
les prend en pleine figure comme
beaucoup d'autres secteurs
professionnels dans notre pays autre
sujet qui est du enfin qui lui aussi
relève on va dire de la conjonction
nationale voire internationale mais nous
allons avoir à faire c'est l'entreprise
pardon va avoir affaire une facture
énergétique extrêmement importante
sénateurs et les collectivités
territoriales ici réunies qui me
démentiront je relevé quelques chiffres
juste pour illustrer devant la
commission facture énergétique tout
confondu de la RATP en 2021-210 millions
d'euros en 2022 l'année n'est pas fini
le tour de 265 et on prévoit en 2023
dans une fourchette là encore vous mal
d'excuserez entre 480 et 550 millions
d'euros bon
je rappelle que la RATP consomme chaque
année
2,5 TER
en énergie tout confondu et que ça
représente 2% de la consommation
électrique de toute l'Île de France
donc c'est dire que la tension sur les
prix mais RATP n'y est évidemment pour
rien pèse et va peser et qu'il va
falloir voir les dispositifs nationaux
l'état etc à chaque fois je pourrais
dire monsieur Tabaro ce président voilà
par exemple on aura tous compris par
rapport à la vie d'un chat PvP il y a
pas de doute je peux m'adresser sans
difficulté au gouvernement puisque ça a
été rappelé les réserves de la RATP
concernent le secteur de l'ouverture à
la concurrence et pour le purger à ce
stade
je n'ai pas besoin non plus de rappeler
oscinateur que ceux qui organise
l'ouverture à la concurrence ceux qui a
l'autisme ce qui décide des lauréats des
lots
ce n'est pas le gouvernement
je rappelle bien ça bon
donc la conjoncture l'inflation sur le
coût de l'énergie nous allons avoir de
la même façon vous avez cité le
mouvement de grève ou un social d'après
demain évidemment pression sur les
salaires ça se passe là non plus que la
RATP soit le seul entreprises le seul
établissement concerné par ce sujet bon
l'occasion pour rappeler devant le la
Commission le Sénat que d'ores et déjà
son contrôle dans cette année 2022 qui
n'est pas terminé
l'augmentation moyenne des rémunérations
à la RATP a été de plus
5,2% en 2022 il y a bien sûr l'effet du
point d'indice que vous connaissez en
juillet mais il y a eu toute une série
de primes qui ont été
décidées après négociation et dont je
constate avec satisfaction qu'elles ont
concernées surtout les basses salaires
qu'elles ont permis aussi de mieux payer
les travail de nuit grâce à un qui a été
conclu au printemps dernier bref il y a
déjà des choses qui ont été faites mais
on voit bien dans ce secteur comme dans
d'autres qu'il y a une pression forte
par rapport à ces tendances
infasionniste je mettrai aussi dans les
défis de demain là sans doute l'impact
la réforme des retraites sur la RATP sur
lequel on aura sans doute l'occasion de
revenir
et puis dans un calendrier tout aussi
exigeant c'est-à-dire pas là dans les
jours dans les semaines qui viennent
mais tout ça se prépare dès à présent et
à même bien évidemment commencer à
l'être avant mon éventuel arrivée
d'abord évidemment la Coupe du monde de
rugby et les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques c'est ça va être une
sacrée à faire bon je ne me lance pas
parce que sans doute vous vous
souvenez-vous toutes et tous que j'ai
été délégué intermittériel aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques avant d'être
Premier ministre donc je j'avais déjà
beaucoup balisé et est connu ce sujet
mais enfin les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 ça va être pour
certains jours un million de voyageurs
supplémentaires à prendre en charge un
million pas tous les jours mais certains
d'entre eux que il y a derrière ça un
enjeu biéthique comme on dit
considérable puisque l'objectif en tout
cas c'est que le taux de clients vous
voyez aussi l'opportunité que ça
représente qui puisse acheter leur
billet de manière digitale soit de au
moins
d'environ 40% vous voyez tout ce que
derrière comme on dit cela suppose
échéance claire mais évidemment majeur
l'ouverture à la concurrence
j'essaie d'être chronologique puisque
les JO c'est l'été 2024 et les
paralympiques en septembre et puis 1er
janvier 2025 en fait je lui dis pas ça
j'ouvertures à comprendre a déjà
commencé non mais pour la RATP c'était
sur des hommes où elle était finalement
très peu donc sur ces zones elle a gagné
d'ailleurs quelques appels d'offres tout
n'est pas terminé elle a répondu si j'ai
bien lu à 1/2 environ mais le premier
janvier 2025 c'est sûr
les hommes bus qu'elle exploite
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez
parfaitement que cette ouverture à la
concurrence va s'exercer bon donc et
puis vous connaissez les échanges
suivantes 2030 pour le tramway et de
1040 pour le métro
et enfin
c'est déjà pas mal parce que ça me
paraît central au-delà tout ça en
facteur commun
ni à courte ni à moyen ni à longue
écharse à toutes les échéances il y a
évidemment
l'enjeu du changement climatique et qui
est devant nous et la contribution que
peut que doit y apporter la RATP et
alors le premier je le dis bien pour
vous fixer la conscience que jamais et
dans les ambitions et les intentions qui
qui sont les miennes enfin les miennes
qui sont celles d'un collectif la
première façon de répondre à ça pour la
RATP
et c'est pour ça que ça peut paraître
paradoxal il y en ayant annoncé les
difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui pour
assurer la qualité de service alors même
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs que tous
les usagers d'avant covid ne sont pas
encore revenus ça s'améliore
ça s'améliore mais on n'est pas encore
le week-end on y est presque
vous avez du mal à satisfaire ça bon
mais pour autant il faut d'autant plus
régler ce sujet qu'en fait l'ambition de
la RATP au nom de l'État au nom du pays
au nom du DFM bien entendu ça doit être
de gagner des parts de marché c'est
indispensable elle a d'abord un premier
grand défi quantitatif les transports
vous le savez représentent 31% des
émissions du gaz à effet de serre bien
plus que l'agriculture que l'indusée etc
et en leur sain la route 94% bon
à distance égale à l'Île-de-France c'est
peut-être pas par exemple tout à fait la
même chose avec
on utilise on consomme 50 fois moins de
CO2 en métro en RER ou en tramway qu'en
voiture donc le grand défi de la RATP
c'est de conquérir des clients
et des autres dans le cas de l'ouverture
à la congrès sont les managers je
m'exprime que non parlons de la RATP je
n'avais pas encore le droit mais enfin
dans cette perspective là évidemment bon
donc
les déplacements en Île-de-France sont
accrues je vous rappelle le 41 43
millions disent les rapports sur les 20
dernières années et les transports
publics ont eu une progression de 14%
sur cette période
donc ça c'est le premier grand sujet il
faut nous être positionné
stratégiquement pour gagner des parts de
marché et puis nous devons aussi
concourir à la lutte contre le
changement climatique en agissant comme
l'entreprise a magnifiquement commencé
de le faire sur sa propre sobriété elle
s'est fixée des objectifs mais je n'ai
rien à dire à ce stade monsieur le
rapporteur et j'essaierai de les mettre
en oeuvre d'abaisser de 50% ses propres
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
50% la base c'est 2015 l'arrivée c'est
2025 et si on prend comme point
d'arrivée 2034 c'est
80%, comment je rappelle Alain mopot
très vu le plan bus
vous irez faire référence un plan quand
même
fondamental puisque évidemment là où le
bât blesse c'est les bus utilisant le
gasoil dans le parc RATP plan bus
extrêmement ambitieux voulu et financé
il faut le rendre hommage par
Île-de-France mobilité enveloppe d'un 8
milliards que la RATP met un œuvre
conversion à 50% électrique biométhane
avec un objectif il faudra tout faire
pour l'atteindre ce rapporteur je n'en
rajoute pas parce que ça va être déjà
très exigeant fin 2026 plus de bus au
diesel
c'est je crois que j'ai là des personnes
qui ont les les pieds très sur terre et
ils voient la hauteur de cette ambition
mais je rend hommage à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui au moment où je m'exprime
devant vous 57% de la cible est déjà
atteinte il y a pas mal 564 bus
électriques 794 bus roulant au
biométhane et 361 ont été injectés si je
puis dire dans le parc de la RATP depuis
le 1er janvier 2022 alors il faut y
aller à marche forcer c'est très
difficile parce que il y a le problème
d'achat
les fournisseurs arrivent pas toujours à
suivre il y a les centres bus
reconvertir et là si je vous dis qu'il
peut y avoir ici un problème de permis
de construire ici un problème de
réglementation
ICPE enfin vous me croirez sur parole
toutes les procédures que le quotidien
tout à fait le quotidien bon mais en
tout cas il faut y aller je réaffirme
devant vous cet objectif il est majeur
de la même façon que sur les autres
aspects du plan de sobriété énergétiques
de l'entreprise et bien il faut baisser
de 20% la consommation énergétique des
bâtiments de la RATP il faut augmenter
la part du renouvelable dans la
fourniture d'électricité pour tous ces
buts pour le métro pour le tramway pour
le RER voilà et il faut aussi évidemment
mener à bien et approfondir sans doute
le chantier de la pub et de l'éclairage
dans les stations qui vous le savez est
extrêmement
délicant bref mesdames et les défis ne
manquent pas
et je le dis
ça me motive beaucoup je le dis et je le
répète alors quelles sont mes priorités
pour y faire face
je voudrais d'abord dire parce que c'est
important
quelques mots sur la méthode d'abord je
pense qu'il faut surtout à mon âge et
éviter de se changer il vaut mieux faire
ce qu'on sait faire et mettre l'accent
là-dessus donc écoute concertation
proximité
écoute concertation proximité c'est une
entreprise
énormément de salariés encore plus de
clients usagers ou d'usagers clients
comme vous voulez il faut être en
permanence
alors écoute et travailler dans la
concertation le premier de grands
partenaires je le dis ici cet après-midi
le président le rapporteur c'est
évidemment
Île-de-France mobilité la RATP je le
rappelle à la commission réalise des
trois quarts de son chiffre d'affaires
99 200 résultats consolidés avec
Île-de-France mobile et je le dis ici je
vois vous avez eu il y a des balles à
présidente s'exprime c'est-à-dire la
première personne que j'irai voir
nous avons l'obligation à travailler
ensemble
et de bien travailler ensemble pour
l'usager savoir si tel ou tel problème
relève d'idfm au-delà RATP
je doute c'est pareil
et des autres en bas ça n'expliquer
entre nous mais mon objectif puisque
c'est la question que vous me posiez ben
voilà je vais proposer à la peur de la
RTP encore qu'on fasse un état des lieux
très précis qu'est-ce qui marche
qu'est-ce qui marche pas bien et que
nous essayons d'avoir un plan d'action
concerté nous avons l'obligation de
travailler ensemble au bénéfice des
Franciliens ou des franciliens et de
tous les visiteurs ou ou touristes qui
utilisent ces transports en commun gérés
par la RATP voilà et évidemment
en serez-vous surpris dans mes messieurs
l'ancien maire que je suis au delà d'ifm
mobilité du conseil régional fera le
tour des collectivités des mairies des
départements sur lesquels notre
entreprise
à
déploie son service public ou va
déployer puisque comme je le disais tout
à l'heure il y a des parts de marché si
je puis dire qu'ils ont été gagné
l'ouverture à la concurrence n'oublions
jamais marche dans les deux sens dieu
merci
évidemment ce dialogue ai-je besoin de
vous le dire j'ai je n'ose dire que j'ai
fait ça toute ma vie
professionnelle et politique
sera aussi exercé il y en aura bien
besoin à l'endroit des partenaires
sociaux de l'entreprise évidemment c'est
une entreprise où le dialogue social a
une histoire et une spécificité et il
vaut mieux comment dire ne pas le
récuser
mais c'est absolument indispensable et
donc il marche d'ailleurs je le dis au
passage il y a un grand mouvement de
grève vous l'avez dit qui d'après ce que
je comprends sera suivi mais ça ne nous
a pas empêché ça n'a pas empêché
l'entreprise de signer rien que en 2021
25 accords d'entreprise si vente quand
même qu'il y a une vitalité du dialogue
social et cette vitalité j'y suis très
attaché et vous avez d'ailleurs pu
Mesdames et Messieurs les Center le
constater lorsque j'étais Premier
ministre
où j'ai poussé au maximum que possible
la concertation avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales ce qu'elles ont
d'ailleurs reconnues donc à court terme
et bien il faudrait essayer je vais
m'employer à faire aboutir les
discussions autour du fameux cadre
social territorialisé c'est pour les
chauffeurs de bus dans le cadre de
l'ouverture à la congrange avec des
négociations très longues ont eu lieu
non pas abouti à une décision
unilatérale qui a été prise par ma
prédécesseur qui a été contesté devant
le juge il y a une médiation judiciaire
qui est en cours voilà bon tout ça je
prends sans mauvais jeu de mots le train
ou le métro en marche voilà dans le
cadre du respect des autres il faudra
que nous puissions aboutir et de la même
façon pour faire pendant ce que je
disais sur les questions de salariales
nous devons anticiper
la NAO la négociation sur les salaires
annuels obligatoires
pour 2023 et nous avons déjà prévu
qu'elle serait ouverte dès décembre
2022 c'est-à-dire demain puisque nous
sommes au mois de novembre
un troisième point me semble-t-il sur ce
dialogue évidemment il faut que je voie
comment améliorer c'est possible et ce
n'est évidemment pas une critique à
l'endroit de ce qui se fait mais je suis
là pour essayer de faire encore mieux en
tout cas c'est sans doute pour ça que
vous me challengez comme on dit voir
comment on peut travailler encore mieux
avec les usagers leur représentants
clients
usagers de l'entreprise je pense que
c'est un point essentiel ils ont des
modes d'expression qui sont infiniment
renouvelés et c'est des choses qu'il
faut organiser peut-être encore
davantage grâce à ces outils
je souhaite aussi je le dis personne
n'en sera étonné
insister sur la qualité du management à
tous les étages de l'entreprise
il y a eu des réformes
organisationsnelles que le rapporteur a
appelé autour de business
et qu'il faudra donc mener à terme mon
objectif
c'est que
il y a une la plus forte déconcentration
des responsabilités que la ligne
ré-hiérarchique soit le plus investie
possible dispose les plus larges marge
de manœuvre soit responsabilisée pour
qu'on plus près du terrain des solutions
puissent être trouvées à chaque fois
qu'un problème concret se pose dans la
marche de l'entreprise et dans
l'accomplissement du service public
voilà pour la méthode en quelques mots
sur le fond pour ne pas être trop long
là je suis vraiment clair avant vous
c'est pas du tout je le dis pour
Philippe Tabaro je vais revenir une
retour en arrière pas du tout sur la
diversification et la filialisation mais
mais ma priorité des priorités c'est le
cœur de métier et le coeur de métier
c'est répondre aux attentes des
usagers des clients de la RATP bien sûr
je n'y reviens pas à la ponctualité et
la régularité mais aussi j'insiste
devant vous la propreté la sécurité la
lutte contre les fraudes la qualité de
l'information le chantier de la
billetterie que j'ai évoqué à la faveur
des Jeux olympiques mais qui est un
sujet de vie quotidienne et la
diversification des activités j'insiste
est importante elle fait sens mais en
aucune manière elle ne doit nous
détourner de notre mission première et
fondamentale c'est au cœur du pacte
social de cette entreprise alors
l'urgence numéro un je l'ai déjà dit
c'est le manque de personnel les
difficultés à recruter l'absentéisme
l'offre de services donc j'ai eu
communication vous le savez d'ailleurs
mesdames et messieurs de ce que tant
Île-de-France mobilité que l'entreprise
elle-même
a décidé jusqu'au recours à l'intérim
qui est sans doute me semble-t-il la
dernière mesure en date à laquelle il
était fait à peine je me donne trois
semaines pour faire un diagnostic
partagé pour trouver des outils
supplémentaires pour essayer encore plus
enfin on est encore une fois beaucoup
d'employeurs si derrière RATP encore une
fois tu es la seule à chercher des
salariés ça serait mais en tout cas je
pense que c'est un sujet qui est
évidemment capital un mot chat sécurité
que j'ai que j'ai évoqué vous savez que
c'est un sujet là aussi de préoccupation
très fort de nos concitoyens en
particulier sur certaines parties de du
réseau je pense notamment
aux stations du Nord-Est parisien avait
quand même du crack les problèmes de vol
à la tire les problèmes
d'agression
y compris d'agressions à l'égard de
femmes donc là aussi je le dis une de
mes premières visites sera d'aller au
centre de coordination opérationnelle
qui a été mis en place
sous l'autorité du préfet de police en
juillet dernier et voir là aussi ce qui
peut être fait
le service qui s'occupe de ça le GPSR le
groupe de protection de sécurité des
réseaux a lui aussi du mal à recruter
IDFM à bon endroit à la renforcer c'est
très bien donner nous a donné les moyens
de recruter mais on n'y arrive pas on
n'y arrive pas je le dis en toute
transparence si j'ai bien compris
l'objectif est que ce service puisse
avoir 958 agents à la fin de l'année
2022 et je comprends qu'on sera
si on essaie pas de trouver des
solutions alternatives ou subsistent
jusqu'à 920 donc là encore je pense
qu'il c'est une étude la même priorité
finalement mais ça sonne vous dire que
c'est si ces histoires de recrutement je
vais aussi mettre le paquet sur bien sûr
les fonctions de conduite de but mais
aussi sur ces questions de sécurité il y
a par ailleurs je le dis au passage sur
les 45 000 agences contre les pics
5500 d'entre eux qui sont dans les gares
et dans les situations au contact du
public des agents de conduite sont pas
des agents de sécurité parce que les
gens qui renseignent ça la présence
humaine c'est important et ça l'est
d'autant plus mesdames et messieurs
Center que par ailleurs il faut
poursuivre dans ce sens on va développer
le numérique la billettique digitale etc
le fait qu'on puisse avoir ses billets
sur son smartphone et plus avoir de bien
donc il faut à tout prix là aussi que
nous réfléchissons ensemble comment
faire en sorte que la présence humaine
ne disparaisse pas et comment j'ai pas à
ce stade de
solution opérationnelle mais comment
avoir comment si on peut encore
accroître par redéploiement parce que je
suis très soucieux de la qualité de la
gestion renforcer cette présence humaine
de proximité qui ne lui ont pas est au
cœur du service militaire RATP est une
entreprise publique de service public
nous devons humaniser au maximum ce
service
régler les défis du quotidien et
préparer l'avenir et l'avenir dans ce
domaine peut-être plus que dans d'autres
c'est la cohérence avec la fille c'est
Philippe c'est investir
investir je vous le dis mais partout
mais dans celui-là en particulier c'est
capital
d'abord je le dis investir dans ce cas
la première richesse de cet entreprise
les femmes et les hommes qui travaillent
je disais ne dépasser 70 000 salariés il
y a 271 métiers et je voudrais me fixer
trois objectifs après une phase
d'objectif partagé à plantaire d'abord
je crois qu'il est absolument
indispensable je le vois en discutant
parce que je suis un usagé maintenant
qu'on sait que peut-être les commissions
parlementaires m'accorderont leur
confiance et que je viendrai PDG de la
RATP des agents McCord
en permanence il me raconte leur vie
quotidienne vie d'un conducteur de bus
qui n'est pas ça donc on a un enjeu
de vie au travail de qualité du travail
il y a des outils pour ça il y a des
choses qui sont engagées ça sera je le
dis une de mes priorités de la même
façon les difficultés de recrutement que
nous rencontrons aujourd'hui avec
l'Impact qui est le leur sur la
continuité du service et la qualité du
service nous oblige me semble-t-il à
améliorer encore la gestion
prévisionnelle les emplois et les
compétences de la RATP et l'ouverture à
la concurrence aussi donc ça sera un
deuxième chantier le troisième toujours
sur ce domaine de
l'investissement dans l'avenir dans les
compétences
ça consistera par la formation par
l'attractivité à mettre l'accent sur
tout ce qui est la spécificité de la
RATP sur l'excellence sur les métiers
d'avenir sur le numérique sur le
technologique sur l'industrie il y a des
enjeux industriels extrêmement forts
mais aussi j'y faisait référence sur la
qualité de l'accueil l'attention portée
aux clients l'insertion des publics en
difficulté dans les nombreux chantiers
que nous avons alors là il y a trois
chantiers que je suivrai très
personnellement et qui me semble être
extrêmement porteur pour l'avenir de
l'entreprise et puis il y a bien sûr des
investissements matériels qui eux aussi
sont un facteur décisif sur la qualité
du service sur la sécurité sur la
sobriété environnementale si on veut
transporter davantage de gens il faut
accroître l'offre il n'y a pas de secret
regardez par exemple l'automatisation
pour ceux qui connaissent bien le métro
parisien de la ligne 1 qui est
maintenant entrer dans les mœurs qui
fonctionne bien si vous regardez
la ponctualité et la sécurité le nombre
des incidents ça s'est considérablement
amélioré il faut généraliser ça petit à
petit à la mesure de nos moyens mais le
cap est tracé si vous regardez le RER A
je rappelle je crois que c'est la ligne
qui transporte le plus de voyageurs au
monde un million 4 millions 400 000
quotidiens bon et il y a encore
énormément de difficultés mais enfin
grâce aux efforts d'Île-de-France
mobilité et de la RATP on a changé les
voitures on a fait des travaux
d'investissement sur les voies etc
considérable entre 2011 et 2017 ça a eu
des incidences la qualité du service à
ponctualité des trains et sur les
indices satisfaction des usagers même si
je connais bien le rera il reste encore
beaucoup pas faire bon mais on a investi
évidemment on va investir dans du
matériel fer
pour qui va permettre de renouveler 60%
du matériel roulant de la RATP entre
enfin d'ici 2035 c'est considérable ce
matériel il est très intéressant il est
plus sûr les les caisses seront mieux
protégées la consommation électrique
la consommation électrique de ces
nouveaux métrés on va baisser de 20% la
qualité de l'air va s'améliorer parce
que les émissions de particules grâce
aux nouveaux systèmes de freinage
seront diminués etc il y a le grand
chantier du RER B ou là aussi il y a des
commandes de 146 trains entre 2025 et
2030 nextteo etc
donc il faut investir monsieur
rapporteur vous avez tout à fait raison
il faut investir dans le domaine des
transports en Île-de-France comme
ailleurs mais là je parle de la de la
RATP la RATP investit beaucoup là encore
pour rendre hommage à ma prédécesseur et
à Île-de-France mobilité plus 70% donc
augmentation des investissements au 2017
et 2022 rien qu'en 2021 dernière
exercice clos 2,7 milliards d'euros dont
1,2 sur fond propre et le contrat en
cours avec l'idfm vous le savez prévoir
8,4 milliards de relatus le CPR en cours
finance un quart des investissements de
la RATP donc oui il faut dégager
monsieur un porteur je l'ai déjà dit
lorsque j'étais un audition ici je l'ai
déjà dit à la tête il faut à tout prix
dégager des ressources nouvelles
est supplémentaire en tout cas par
rapport à la fameuse trajectoire de la
l'homme que vous connaissez bien je me
permets de rappeler pour faire mention
des fonctions d'ancien Premier ministre
que s'agissant du CER d'Île-de-France
zone je viens de parler j'avais accru de
870 millions la part de l'État dans son
financement essentiellement grâce au
plan de relance pour la porter à 2
milliards 330 millions d'euros c'est à
dire annuel c'est-à-dire fait pardon
globale c'est-à-dire bien au delà de ça
de la au delà de la trajectoire des 200
millions annuels
la politique de diversification et de
filialisation qui est à l'oeuvre depuis
plusieurs années doit participer
pleinement à la valorisation de ces
investissements et dans la cohérence du
groupe voilà donc mes priorités vous me
posent la question là-dessus bien c'est
le métro automatique on est très bien
placé sur le plan national il faut
peut-être plus encore que des résobus
que nous candidats que nous conquerions
des parts de marché dans le métro
automatique il faut que nous ayons une
vision intégrée la RATP est à des
qualités à faire valoir à un
savoir-faire valoir sur la vision
intégrée de la vie et dans ces
conditions dans ces conditions je le dis
nous pourrons relever le défi de
l'ouverture à la concurrence préparer
par mes pas nécessaire je veux affirmer
devant vous ici que le service public
est tout à fait capable avec les valeurs
qui sont les siennes de faire face à ce
défi
réorganisation est quasiment achevée
monsieur Tabarro et nous devons pouvoir
passer du statut d'opérateur en monopole
à celui du statut d'opérateur choisi
simplement il manque encore des textes
il manque encore toute une série de
dispositions qui génèrent de
l'incertitude auprès de nos salariés que
je vais m'employer à lever au plus vite
alors dans ce cas là on est dans
l'ouverture à la concurrence donc
j'appliquerai riz heureusement et les
observations de la hatv et j'en profite
pour dire ça tombe bien le Ministre en
charge
c'est
Monsieur Béchu il n'était pas dans mon
gouvernement je peux donc en respectant
très strictement les termes de
délibération de l'âge atvp et établir
sur ces sujets et c'est ce que je ferais
une relation avec ce ministre sur
l'ouverture à congrès je voulais juste
vous dire une chose je pense qu'il faut
quand même que nous soyons vigilants
c'est pas une religion l'ouverture à
concurrence
moi je suis plutôt de ceux qui pensent
c'est un bon aiguillon mais à condition
que le résultat soit positif et donc je
pense qu'il faut ça commence
il faut le Parlement peut y contribuer
s'il le souhaite qu'on a une sorte
d'observatoire
de l'ouverture à la concurrence que ce
que ça porte qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
nouveaux entrants est-ce
qu'effectivement les primaires c'est ce
que la qualité du service ne se trouve
pas dégradée toute question auxquelles
me semble-t-il et il faut que nous
puissions répondre mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs pendant de cette exposé un peu
long je voulais vous dire à son terme ma
lucidité d'abord face au défi qui sont
les nôtres
ma confiance dans les collaborateurs de
la RATP
m'a détermination à mettre mon
expérience ou plutôt mes expériences au
service de ses défis de cette entreprise
au service de ses clients usagers
expérience du service public car je
crois au service public aux valeurs du
service public qui sont parfaitement
conciliables avec
compétitivité performance et concurrence
à condition qu'elle soit nécessaire
juste et équitable expérience du
dialogue social dans les différences
fonctions qui ont été les miennes je
dirais de l'Intérieur nécessitait du
dialogue social de la considération et
de l'écoute expérience pour préparer les
grands événements qui attendent Paris et
la France et auquel la RATP doit
apporter son entier concours expérience
du terrain du concret des exigences de
la vie quotidienne
à la fois comme ancien maire et comme
utilisateur historique et constant des
transports en commun
l'expérience sans doute aussi
mesdames et messieurs et sénateurs des
situations comment dirions-nous
difficiles
tel que celle que j'ai pu connaître
comme premier ministre mais
ce qui est bien finalement c'est que
j'ai le sentiment que j'ai encore
beaucoup à apprendre
dans ce nouveau défi et que mon
enthousiasme pour le faire
est absolument intact je vous remercie
merci Monsieur pour le Premier ministre
ce propos auliminaire je vais donner la
parole à Joël Bigot
Monsieur le Premier Ministre merci de ce
cours propose
il y a de cela trois mois sans 4 jours
nous disait Philippe Tabaro ici même
nous vous donnions notre accord pour
présider l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport Lafitte
dont votre processeur était monsieur
Béchu d'ailleurs
comme le Parlement là également donné à
Emmanuel wargon pour la présidence de la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie ou
encore à Brigitte bourguignon la Ligas
conformé conformément à l'article 13 de
la Constitution valse des postes bien
huilés et bien utile en début de
quinquennat Philippe Tabaro l'a illustré
tout à l'heure dans son propos initial
mais aujourd'hui c'est sans compter sans
les avis de notre haute autorité de la
transparence de la vie publique en place
depuis 193 et qui apporte au public un
regard nouveau sur ces nominations
en effet l'achat atvp rend pour chaque
nomination un avis circonstancié et
rigoureux sur les conflits d'intérêts
potentiels et les incompatibilités ce
fut le cas pour l'ex ministre des
Transports monsieur Jean-Baptiste
djibari interdit de venir de devenir VP
de CMA CGM ou encore Frédéric Vidal qui
ex ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
interdite de rejoindre une école de
commerce favorisée par des subventions
concernant votre corps Monsieur le
Premier Ministre la Haute Autorité ne
dit pas non mais elle émet des réserves
importantes qui peuvent faire douter les
parlementaires que nous sommes du bon
exercice des fonctions pour lesquelles
vous nous demandez votre soutien et pour
lesquels vous tentez d'apporter des
réponses
ainsi comment envisager que le nouveau
président de la RATP ne puisse de sa
propre initiative contacter les
ministres tels que l'actuel ministre des
Transports mais également
et même la première ministre mais
également l'interdiction de toute
démarche envers les services
anciennement sous votre direction et ce
jusqu'au 16 mai 2025 alors que la
Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France en appel à votre pugnacité
après je cite d'un gouvernement qui
regarde ailleurs
pensez-vous pouvoir honorer cette
mission avec de telles restrictions
certes cet avis n'est pas défavorable
mais il compliquera grandement votre
tâche dans un contexte chargé
d'ouverture à la concurrence vous l'avez
dit des transports publics en
Île-de-France et à quelques encablures
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 n'y avait-il pas d'autres candidats
au poste auxquels vous prétendez un
process un processus de recrutement
était pourtant engagé et de nombreux
candidats étaient en cours d'audition
par ailleurs je dois dire que votre
candidature confirme les reproches que
la Cour des comptes a pu adresser à
Lafitte qualifiée par les sages de la
rue Cambon de quasi coquille vide cette
nouvelle candidature pourrait-elle
annoncer un recul sur des projets
ferroviaires nationaux structurants
alors que nous avons tant besoin
d'investissement dans ce domaine
pensez-vous pouvoir mener de front cette
double présidence et comptez-vous
démissionner de la fuite
vous l'avez compris monsieur le Premier
ministre nous ne multiplierons pas les
informations les interventions l'objet
de notre opposition ne portera donc pas
tant sur vos compétences éprouvées que
sur l'obstination du président de la
République a préféré le bras de fer à la
transparence c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous opposerons à votre
nomination à la présidence de la RATP je
vous remercie
[Musique]
merci Monsieur Jacques
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre donc j'ai un certain
nombre de questions donc au nom de mon
groupe d'abord
ce cheminement inédit qui va sans doute
aboutir à votre nomination à la tête de
la RATP à soulever déjà en lui-même des
interrogations on y a déjà fait
largement allusion cette bifurcation
étonnante qui vous fait lâcher à peine
arrivé l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport au profit
de la RATP peut quand même passer pour
une certaine désinvolture à l'égard de
la fuite d'abord et puis un petit peu
des auditions et avis auxquels avaient
déjà procédé nos commissions
parlementaires cela méritait des
explications
et l'argument que nous avons entendu que
vous venez de développer sur le fait que
le poste soit devenu vacant après coup
ne lève pas complètement toute notre
incompréhension sur le risque de
conflits d'intérêts donc liés à votre
ancienne fonction de chef du
gouvernement
la vie de la Haute autorité sur la
transparence de la vie publique n'a
manifestement pas été limpide du premier
coup pour tout le monde c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire même s'il conclut
c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité donc c'est
conséquences sur l'exercice pratique de
votre président ne sont pas totalement
évidentes au-delà de ces questions de
méthode et déontologie qui vont quand
même un peu peser sur notre vote se pose
des questions vous avez déjà commencé à
y répondre en partie sur votre vision et
votre feuille de route pour la RATP donc
comment non seulement enrayer la
dégradation actuelle de ce service
public mais aussi réussir à hisser
l'offre à la hauteur de nos ambitions de
progression en par modal vous parliez de
l'enjeu climatique
coût de l'électricité de l'énergie des
difficultés de recrutement l'a dit de
formation des lourds investissements
nécessaires
la décarbonation particulièrement
l'électrification des bus qui
nécessitera
des moyens importants tant que la
massification de la production ne fera
pas baisser le coup donc il y en a des
freins et des défis qui sont importants
comment aussi mener à bien les les
transformations lourdes que nécessitent
les carences d'accessibilité de notre
réseau aux personnes handicapées et puis
le chantier vous y avez fait brièvement
allusion le chantier important de la
qualité de l'air dans notre métro qui
connaît des taux élevés de particules
fines que ça soit l'abrasion le freinage
les soulèvements de poussière ça fait
qu'au total on atteint quand même des
taux dans l'air de plus de trois fois
plus élevé fait quelquefois trois fois
plus élevé que dans l'air extérieur
comment enfin
ce processus progressif vous en rappeler
les échéances d'ouverture à la
concurrence pourraient ne pas engendrer
désorganisation
inégalités atteinte à la continuité du
service public
merci je vais donner la parole à Gérard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre
après Philippe tabaron permettez-moi
d'exprimer aussi un peu d'inquiétude
quant à l'avenir de Lafitte à laquelle
il ne faut cesser de penser
et nous pensions après l'acte majeur que
nous avions commis ici avoir stabilisé
un peu la situation de ce côté-là
mais
le besoin éprouvé
d'envisager votre candidature
au poste dont nous parlons en ce moment
à mon avis constituent les gens un
événement
c'est quand même pas très habituel
dans un laps de temps aussi court de
boire l'ancien Premier ministre appelé
envisager de d'assurer de telles de
telles fonctions
par conséquent ce serait tenté de dire
comme première observation que
l'hypothèse de votre
candidature qui n'est plus une
candidature a confirmé
au nord en quelque sorte vos compétences
si ça n'avait pas été le cas personne
n'aurait pensé à vous donc par
conséquent vous demande de bien vouloir
accepter que nous partageons les
motivations qui ont pu conduire d'aucun
et en premier le président de la
République a pensé à vous
mais je pense aussi qu'on a pensé à vous
au regard de l'ampleur de l'attache à
accomplir
et au regard des grandes difficultés qui
sont devant nous et que je ne
rappellerai pas ici
mais la RATP vit une situation de crise
et ce n'est pas qu'une crise qui se
rapporte à la région parisienne
c'est au fond une crise qui affecte une
entreprise nationale vous l'avez rappelé
et moi qui vient de Bretagne je sais que
le groupe intervient aussi
dans un certain nombre de nos localités
bretonnes
vous avez bien voulu rappeler que
évidemment là chacun a ses
responsabilités
mais
je serai tenté de dire
de me faire ici l'écho de toutes les
il y a effectivement il de France
mobilité
mais toutes les AOM de France sont
confrontés à des difficultés plus encore
depuis la crise covid
et toutes on va faire face à des
véritables défis ce notamment découlant
de la baisse de la fréquentation que
nous n'avons pas reconquise et par
conséquent nécessite quelque part une
grande ambition publique afin que cesoms
qui sont des collectivités
territoriales soit en mesure d'assumer
leurs responsabilités je pense à toute à
toutes les AOM
aussi et puis d'autres difficultés vous
l'avez rappelé sont
devant nous les conséquences de la crise
énergie etc et je ne développerai pas
au regard de cette situation à laquelle
sont confrontés nos transports d'une
façon générale
notre approche
n'est donc pas non plus
une approche d'exercice qu'on veut
nous avons souhaitons être délicat nous
voulons reconnaître évidemment ce que
sont les compétences appréciées de
chacun et en l'occurrence les vôtres
notre démarche ne sera pas non plus donc
une démarche de suspicion à votre égard
mais à l'égard de votre candidature
mais nous aurions aimé en tant que
parlementaire
avoir à débattre de tout ce que je
rappelais tout à l'heure la situation
des AEM la situation des transports dans
quelle situation quelle situation
faut-il surmonter etc
nous avons eu l'occasion d'ailleurs de
le rappeler à maintes réunion ici en
réunion de commission et y compris en
séance publique au Sénat
dans ces conditions là
et outre je dirais les remarques qui ont
été faites par un autre collègue à
l'instant qui sont de nature marqués
rappelle je dirais les doutes qui
peuvent entourer la procédure
outre tout ceci le fait de n'avoir pas
été de n'être toujours pas en situation
d'aborder au fond la situation des
transports des situations sociales qui
en découlent l'absence de conducteur un
peu partout comme vous l'avez rappelé
tout ceci nous conduit a décidé
de refuser de participer au vote de tout
à l'heure
merci j'ai donné la parole à Bruno Belin
et puis après je serai Premier ministre
moi je vais conclure je vais commencer
comme un conclure le rapporteur
c'est-à-dire voilà prendre acte
indiscutable de la compétence du
candidat et lui dire a-t-il personnel et
ma confiance
deux sujets sur le Premier ministre sur
le candidat premier j'ai bien entendu
que vous voulez gagner des parts de
marché et ça commence effectivement par
cette image voilà récurrente permanente
de grève à la RATP
une grève à la RATP c'est Paris paralysé
c'était les travail forcé et ces crises
de nerfs assurées donc comment on arrive
finalement et peut-être qu'on a un
moment donné on évaluera ça le nombre de
grève de jour de grève par an en tout
cas comment on arrive à un modèle de
satisfaction pour que l'usager s'y
retrouve vous avez évoqué rapidement
mais c'est un sujet sur lequel je tenais
à vous questionner j'ai eu l'occasion et
quelques mois de découvrir le métro de
Berlin j'avais l'impression d'être dans
un bloc opératoire
je vous invite à y aller
la question de la propreté à Paris et
quand même quelque chose qui nous
préoccupe et sur lesquels voilà on a
besoin d'avoir vos éléments de combat
c'est comme celui de la sécurité puis
question subsidiaire parce que vous
connaissez bien le sujet on en a parlé
il y a quelques années déjà ensemble
quand nous préparions Paris 2024 même si
c'est déjà Express ne relève pas de la
compétence de la RATP il ne sera pas
fait cherchant il ne sera pas fait pour
juillet 2024 donc comment allons-nous
faire pour
irriguer et effectivement
désengorgé se Nord Paris sur l'accès
important qui va y avoir à ce moment
dans cet événement exceptionnel pour la
France merci monsieur le président
merci chers collègues je vais proposer
monsieur Premier ministre à mes
collègues sur ce merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président
alors d'abord
je comprends que vous regrettiez
amèrement mon départ de l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport j'en profite oui bien sûr je
vais pas cumuler avec une telle sorte
d'incompatibilité les deux fonctions
quelqu'un qui donc pour être très précis
en termes procédural normalement si les
commissions des assemblées
juridique suivant c'est un décret mais
nommant au conseil d'administration de
la RATP
et le même décret parallèle ou
concomitant me dénommant de l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures
transports je le dis parce que il me
semble il faut que ce soit clair
là-dessus et
bon c'est pas une bifurcation on va
parler de bifurcation ce terme je crois
pas enfin j'ai compris que vous ne
m'accorderiez pas le bénéfice de votre
vote je regrette évidemment
c'est vous la bifurcation pardon bon et
oui vous avez raison pardon je vais
faire bon voilà mais
en tout cas le résultat sera le même au
moins pourriez-vous m'accorder le
bénéfice de la cohérence je reste dans
le champ des transports publics et des
investissements qui représentent je
reviens pas sur ce que je vous ai dit
dans mon propos introductif bon la fiche
c'était très important j'ai essayé de
faire de mon mieux les cimetières sont
remplis de gens indispensables donc je
j'espère fortement que celle ou celui
qui remplacera poursuivra le travail que
nous avions cher monsieur le rapporteur
ébauché et l'amplifiera pourquoi pas bon
mais je sais moi je me réfère monsieur
et Mesdames Messieurs à ce que j'ai dit
aux françaises aux Français le jour où
j'ai quitté l'hôtel Matignon
publiquement j'ai dit
je quitte le chant de la vie politique
nationale
mais je veux continuer à me rendre utile
bon ben c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
et à mon ami conscience c'est vous êtes
libre de ne pas le partager
je considère que j'étais très utile
j'espère la fixe mais il me semble que
je le saurai j'espère en tout cas encore
plus à la RATP Papot je cherche pas à
dire que la RATP c'est mieux que la fift
tout va bien mais que les enjeux sont
évidemment différents notamment les
enjeux managériaux voilà donc nous
sommes qu'à la fois continuité pardon
pour
l'imputabilité de la bifurcation et
cohérence en tout cas dans dans les
choix qui sont les biens vous êtes les
uns les autres revenus sur la vie de la
hatvp bon moi j'ai envie de vous dire il
m'appartient pas de commenter les avis
de la chatte et l'épée mais de les
appliquer bon et c'est ce que je vais
faire je crois qu'il était très utile et
j'en remercie s'il le permet monsieur le
rapporteur que si interprétation il doit
y avoir elle soit faite si c'est moi qui
interprète vis-à-vis de l'achat de TVP
il y a quelque chose qui tombe pas bien
rond c'est à la hatv p elle-même de dire
porter et limite de ces dispositions et
au législateur de dire ce qu'il en pense
par ailleurs bon
là aussi je me permets là pour le coup
de bien
repréciser que et Monsieur Migaud la des
lunettes y compris le public
publiquement que les restrictions que
vous avez à bon droit rappeler
s'applique sur une partie certes
importante de ce qui sera à mon mandat
l'ouverture à la concurrence de
quelqu'un j'ai pas parlé du ministre
intérieur pas intérieur pour la sécurité
précédentes on n'est pas dans le champ
d'ouverture Agora c'est que je respecte
parfaitement la vie de la chatte IP si
j'appelle le ministre intérieur pour les
négociations salaires pour les prix de
l'énergie que
quand évoqué si je veux appeler le
ministre de l'Économie je suis tout à
fait conforme à la vie de la HTP
d'autant je me permets d'insister auprès
de vous comme j'avais je l'avais
d'ailleurs rappelé à la Haute Autorité
encore une fois d'autant que les
questions d'ouverture à la concurrence
sont organisées par l'OM c'est-à-dire
Île-de-France mobilité c'est pas le
gouvernement qui fait les lots c'est pas
le gouvernement qui choisira les
lauréats et donc si je comprends
parfaitement ce que dit la hashtv ça il
faut pas que je bénéficie de mon statut
d'ancien Premier ministre pour
influencer le choix du décideur de mes
anciens collègues pour allouer tel ou
telôme j'allais dire là pour le coup ça
tombe bien ce ne sont pas mes anciens
collègues gouvernement qui ont offert ce
choix bon je comprends parfaitement
messieurs les sénateurs vont
questionnements là-dessus mais il me
semble et d'ailleurs moi ce que j'ai
fait voyant ça puisqu'il y avait
effectivement des questions
d'interprétation j'ai écrit après la
délibération au président Migaud qui m'a
répondu parce que vous vous avez des
interrogations parfaitement légitimes
mais moi encore plus je j'engage ma
responsabilité si vous avez compris
personnelle bon et donc il a clarifié
dans le sens évidemment qu'à rappeler le
rapporteur la situation donc voilà si
j'avais vous voyez encore une fois moi
mon objectif c'est pas de de chercher un
poste ou un honneur c'est d'être utile
si j'avais le sentiment évidemment avec
cet avis je ne pouvais pas exercer les
responsabilités qui sont appelées je
serai pas de devant vous mais je ne
cherche pas je le dis par rapport à ce
que j'ai entendu être recasé d'habitude
dans ce recase à dessiner cul je vous
dis je suis pas tout à fait sûr que en
soi dans le sujet et j'ajoute que j'ai
pas je je veux dire j'étais quasi enfin
j'ai pas je suis pas là à part de moi de
vous le dire le sujet je comprends tout
ce que vous dites mais mon sujet n'est
pas celui moi sujet je l'ai dit aux
Français est-ce que l'expérience que
j'ai accumulé peut être utilisé pour
ceux qui tiennent au service public il y
en a tous ici réunis mais oui
effectivement il y avait d'autres
malheureusement quelqu'un qui avait
d'autres candidats à la tête
d'entreprise comme ça mais c'est
merveilleux là la RATP malgré toutes les
difficultés heureusement qu'il y avait
d'autres candidats bon ben oui c'est
vrai que je suis pas
issu du privé pur et du monde
d'entreprise ce qu'il y a des vertus et
des qualités mais peut-être aussi
d'ayions-nous considérer que le fait
d'avoir une vision une expérience
politique par rapport à tous les sujets
qui sont face à la RATP aujourd'hui
peut-être un plus ou en tout cas n'est
pas un inconvénient voilà
juste pour moi parce que je suis Alex
sur la situation des awens et des
transports effectivement ça mérite très
peut-être un autre débat que dans cet
enceinte c'est un président oui sur la
propreté juste c'est que je peux pas
faire de réponse précise je débarque
mais j'ai vu qu'il y a un nouveau marché
qui a été passé là qui me sur toutes les
en tout cas pour le les gars les
stations qui me paraît extrêmement
porteur de progrès on va voir à son
exécution mais je vais effectivement
m'occuper de la propreté et dans un tout
autre registre
si le char de Gaulle Express intéresse
la RATP parce qu'il y a une jeune
venture c'est ça une jeune venture qui
est faite avec
avec la SNCF avec Keolis merci
il y a longtemps conseil c'est déjà mon
prédécesseur qui avait dû en prendre
acte que le Charles de Gaulle Express ne
sera pas terminé pour 2024 d'accord non
plus d'ailleurs si on ne va plus loin
que la ligne 17 qui elle aussi je le
rappelle aux honorables parlementaires
et censé rejoindre un jour l'aéroport
Charles de Gaulle étoile l'aéroport
Charles de Gaulle tout court bon donc
oui on aura donc ce sujet ça veut dire
que pour être clair le RER B
bon dans la partie nord qui relève de
l'exploitation de la de la SNCF sur ce
tronçon mais va être encore plus
sollicité pour les jeux donc ça fait
partie du plan de transport que pilote
en l'espèce IDFM
merci j'ai donné la parole à Guillaume
chevrolier
merci
j'ai oublié de je tiens à la
distribution le mettra peut-être au
compte-rendu le nombre de jours de grève
par salarié le nombre d'alarmes
peut-être ce sera intéressant pour le
l'information de la Commission
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
été enfin vous allez être président de
la fille pendant deux mois et 19 jours
vous avez été premier ministre pendant
un an et dix mois vous avez été
président de l'Agence nationale du sport
pendant un an et deux mois secrétaire
général adjoint de la présidence de la
République pendant un an et deux mois
conseillé aux affaires sociales pendant
deux ans je m'arrête là sur votre CV
alors je ne doute pas de vos compétences
pour présider la RATP mais ce que vous
vous tiendrez les 5 ans sur un même
poste puisque c'est la durée du mandat à
la tête de la RATP et comme vous les
avez très bien développé la RATP face à
de très nombreux enjeux ou je pense il
est important d'avoir à sa tête une
direction une présidence dans la durée
pour pour mener à bien tous les tous les
chantiers parmi lesquels la qualité du
réseau la régularité que vous avez aussi
évoqué dans votre propos liminaire
et aussi la question du financement avec
la dette covid de l'augmentation de le
coût de l'énergie le financement des
nouvelles lignes il manque il manquera
de de l'argent à la RATP pour faire face
à de nombreuses dépenses alors que
pensez-vous de l'augmentation du Pass
Navigo à 100 euros est-ce socialement
supportable que les usagers
seuls payent tous les surcos et faute de
modification de texte sur le versement
mobilité
par rapport à la région
Île-de-France vous avez déjà répondu sur
la question de la sécurité et puis je
voudrais revenir sur une question qui a
été abordée par un collègue non pas sur
la propreté mais sur la qualité de l'air
qui est un sujet majeur siégeant au
Conseil national de l'air on sait qu'il
y a un niveau de taux de particules
fines plus élevé dans les transports en
commun source d'inquiétude pour les
usagers donc quelle mesure comptez-vous
prendre pour ce sujet qui est un autre
sujet majeur je vous remercie
merci je n'ai la parole à Michel Dagbert
[Musique]
certains nombre de collègues en
conviendront à largement couvert le
spectre d'un certain nombre de questions
que nous avions sans doute préparé à
votre endroit mais cela vient montrer et
nous n'en doutions pas non plus à quel
point vous êtes déjà impliqué dans cette
future fonction que à titre personnel
j'espère vous voir occuper
un petit peu sur les questions que
j'avais
imaginez-vous poser bon nombre de
réponses en d'ores et déjà été apportées
pour autant
se tient à Charmel shake la Coop 27 et
l'entreprise dont il est question
aujourd'hui vous l'avez d'ailleurs
mentionné dans votre propos est à ce
titre un consommateur important en
matière d'énergie et donc quelle
stratégie pensez-vous mettre en oeuvre
afin d'atteindre des objectifs vertueux
en la matière et j'avais un deuxième
point qui lui aussi a été fortement
abordé et vous l'avez mentionné
quelle stratégie managériale
entendez-vous mettre en oeuvre afin de
faire en sorte que ce service public à
l'égard de l'usager mais aussi et vous
l'avez mentionné à l'égard des clients
et à la veille d'un certain nombre
rendez-vous éminemment important des
rendez-vous mondiaux tels que la Coupe
du monde de rugby mais aussi les Jeux
olympiques de 2024 sont aussi d'une
certaine manière une vitrine de
l'excellence que peut représenter cette
entreprise et notamment dans la conquête
de marché à l'international merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je ne doute pas de vos
capacités à
gérer donc cette nouvelle entre cette
entreprise et j'avais deux questions à
vous poser
la première c'est ce sont les recettes
fiscales de l'État est-ce qu'elles
doivent
être mis en place à l'Île de France
mobilité pour tenir l'engagement qui a
été pris par
Édouard Philippe Premier ministre en
janvier 2020 puisque je rappelle que le
premier ministre Édouard Philippe avait
engagé l'État sur les financements
additionnels et des transferts de
recettes pour couvrir le milliard
d'euros de dépenses annuelle
d'exploitation supplémentaire en
contrepartie de la couverture des
dépenses de prêt-exploitation pour la
RATP par Île-de-France mobilité
et puis alors ça je pense que cette
question a été posée déjà mais ça me
paraît important de de la reposer c'est
le financement de la pré-exploitation du
Grand Paris Express je pense que c'est
un sujet prégnant puisque c'est
imminent de mettre en place Grand Paris
avec les Jeux Olympiques notamment
et puis
une autre question mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui est récurrent concernant la
lutte contre les arrêts maladie qui sont
abusifs RATP et puis bon les grèves
perlées qui ont tendance à un peu tout
désorganiser mais là je pense que vous
avez peut-être des réponses vous avez
apporté déjà une partie des réponses
mais si je voudrais avoir quelques
éléments supplémentaires
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Fabien Genet
tu le Président Monsieur le Premier
Ministre
d'abord une petite confidence j'avais le
sentiment
j'ai le Premier ministre d'avoir un peu
le même problème que vous l'été dernier
lorsque nous vous avons auditionné sur
la présidence de Lafitte et je
m'explique parce que vous étiez venu en
Saône-et-Loire sur la RCEA garantir les
financements de la mise à 2 x 2 voies
vous étiez venu au plus près de chez moi
inauguré les pistes de l'aéroport de
Saint-Yorre à la vitesse de mes amis
mère Georges Borda et Elisabeth ponceau
et effectivement lorsque j'ai dû voter
pour savoir si je vous envoyais avec mes
collègues à Lafitte imaginant que
j'aurai à négocier avec vous le
financement des deux viaducs qui restent
à financer sur la SEA le viaduc de
Charolles et le viaduc de la Roche La
Roche de celui très pour mes collègues
socialistes
ok il peut être attaché ou qu'ils
peuvent connaître pour quelques voyages
qu'ils auraient pu réaliser dans les
années 80 je m'étais dit est-ce que
déontologiquement je suis vraiment
je ne suis pas à la veille d'un conflit
d'intérêts en envoyant monsieur Castex à
la fitte alors effectivement aujourd'hui
vous voir quitter lafit c'est m'enlever
un grand poids dont je voulais vous
remercier mais au-delà
au-delà de ce trait d'humour
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites
mais formellement pour vous protéger
monsieur le Premier ministre
est-il exact que la délibération qui
concerne la vie de la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
dont on parle et bien la délibération
numéro 2022 380 du 18 octobre 22
celle qui dans son alien 8 considère que
Monsieur Castex devra et vous
permettrait de la lire dans le cadre de
sa nouvelle activité professionnelle
s'abstenir de toutes démarches y compris
de représentation d'intérêt auprès des
membres du gouvernement en exercice
qu'il était également lorsqu'il était
Premier Ministre ainsi des membres de
son cabinet qui occupent encore des
fonctions publiques etc etc dans cette
délibération je ne vois pas du tout ce
que vous nous avez dit
sur la précision de l'ouverture à
l'ouverture des marchés vous nous dites
que vous avez contacté le président de
la le président de la Haute Autorité
est-ce qu'il y a eu auquel cas une
nouvelle délibération formelle de cette
haute autorité dans les mêmes formes que
celle que nous venons de citer
voilà pour la première interrogation la
deuxième interrogation
pour les viaducs que j'ai cités mais
également pour toutes les autres
infrastructures je m'associe à mes
collègues sur le regret de voir partir
un président
que nous avions dont nous avions validé
la nomination l'été dernier je n'aurais
pas doutrecu danse de vous demander si
vous savez
qui pourrait bien vous remplacer dans
ces fonctions parce que vous
m'accorderait que remplacer un ancien
Premier ministre dans des fonctions
comme celle-ci ça va pas être simple
alors peut-être que à l'heure où Paris
bruit
[Musique]
de menaces de dissolution peut-être que
une future ancienne première ministre
finalement pourraient venir occuper dans
quelques mois ou quelques semaines vos
fonctions
nous verrons bien en tous les cas il
serait il serait bon pour nos
infrastructures et pour les dossiers de
nos territoires que nous ayons très
rapidement effectivement un successeur
et je terminerai pas une troisième
question
ça a été un peu évoqué mais cet été
aussi
il y a eu il y a eu cette incident
majeur dans le cadre de l'organisation
de la finale de la Ligue des champions
au Stade de France le rapport sénatorial
rendu par nos collègues en particulier
Lafont a bien montré que
c'est avant tout au niveau du fait
générateur bien sûr le mouvement de
grève du RER B qui n'avait pas été
suffisamment anticipé qui a provoqué en
cascade tout ce que l'on a connu ensuite
et donc à l'approche de ces grands
rendez-vous que sont la Coupe du monde
de rugby et surtout les Jeux Olympiques
une question peut-être un peu générale
est-ce qu'un pays qui ne s'est pas
garantir à la continuité du service
alors même qu'on parle et vous l'avez
rappelé d'une entreprise publique de
service public est-ce qu'une un tel pays
est à même de recevoir dans de bonnes
conditions les Jeux Olympiques
merci je vais je vais laisser répondre
le Premier ministre les questions qui
sont posées puis après j'ai encore trois
demandes de parole j'y suis une petite
analyse de ce qui se dit
le Premier ministre pourrait être ce que
je ne souhaite pas victime de sa
compétence qui est embêtant quand même
parce que j'entends beaucoup de
compétences qu'on peut vous protéger
votre compétences
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen bon
je veux peut-être vous permettez revenir
sur la déversion de la satellite c'est
une un sujet évidemment important et
juste ici tout y est parce que vous avez
dans la lecture que vous avez faite du
considérant en numéro 8 de la
délibération c'est bien le bon numéro
c'est le début du considérant à cet
effet à cet effet je dois m'abstenir et
le à cet effet envoie donc aux
considérant précédent c'est ce qui
explique monsieur limigo il a pas besoin
de d'autres délibérations et dans le
considérant précédent il dit il est dit
bien que des relations existent
nécessairement entre l'État et un
établissement public enlève il apparaît
nécessaire dans le contexte de mise à
oeuvre de l'ouverture à la concurrence
des transports publics en Île-de-France
d'encadrer les futurs relations etc à
cet effet donc il explique pour la
chatte épée dit comment il va encadrer
au titre de l'ouverture à la concurrence
les relations que je devrais avoir avec
les anciens membres de mon gouvernement
ou les services placés sous mon autorité
voilà donc je pense que ça ça répond et
c'est ce que m'écrit le président Migaud
dans un courrier que je tiens monsieur
le Président à votre disposition le 2
novembre parce que j'avais moi-même eu
les mêmes interrogations que vous mais
ceci me paraît pour le coup clarifier
je reste avec Monsieur Genève j'ai lu
évidemment le rapport sénatorial sur le
Stade de France j'ai vu aussi ce cas
indique la RATP dans les dans les dans
les auditions et notamment les
l'organisation du report sur la ligne D
du RER puisque comme il y avait grève
l'une des conséquences de la grève je
rappelle au-delà de la raréfaction de
l'offre c'est que l'interconnexion comme
on dit n'était pas assurée à la
à la gare du Nord là aussi le hasard a
voulu je n'ai pas cité dont je le fais
maintenant que j'arrive ici en même
temps que monsieur farandou qui était
auditionné par une autre condition de
votre hôte assemblée bon
là aussi je tiens à vous dire combien je
ferai en sorte d'avoir avec la SNCF des
relations très fluides pas toujours
simple et le fameux RER B dont on parle
si un jour quoi vous pouvez arriver les
choses sont considérablement améliorées
mais à buter sur le fait que l'existence
deux gestionnaires l'ont au sud de notre
au nord puisse aboutir à un certain
nombre de complications encore une fois
des choses sont améliorées mais
peut-être y a-t-il encore des horaires
en tout cas j'ai lu avec attention ce
rapport et je m'engage devant vous à il
émet un certain nombre de préconisations
que j'ai lu évidemment nous les
étudierons et
évidemment l'intérêt vous l'avez raison
c'est de c'est l'organisation d'autres
événements alors quand même j'ai été
aussi délégué aux grands événements
sportifs
on a quand même je le dis va à 7h réussi
quand même l'accueil de beaucoup
beaucoup d'événements évidemment selon
l'expression consacrée et adaptée à la
présence d'audition parlent surtout des
trains qui n'arrivent pas à l'heure mais
on a je dirais même la France il y a des
spécialistes dans la salle à une
habitude quand même d'accueil des grands
événements sportifs qui est pas
négligeable mais finalement c'est un
avertissement sans frais qui a été donné
là et il faut que on se remette tous
autour de la table pour pour trouver les
solutions les plus adaptées bon je
reviens alors bon je reviens pas je
voulais sur les durées demanda vous avez
raison ben oui j'étais secrétaire
général
adjoint à l'Élysée il y a eu des
élections présidentielles c'est pas de
mon fait et vous en connaissez le
résultat vous avez raison de dire
j'étais président en agence nationale du
sport et délégué intermisselles et puis
j'ai été appelé pour être Premier
ministre j'ai dû quitter mes fonctions à
l'Agence nationale du sport bon c'est
comme ça ainsi vers la vie mais je vous
dis ça parce que et je sais que c'était
pas l'objet de votre question mais je ne
je suis pas l'organisateur de la briefé
de mes mandats bon ici oui là c'est moi
qui a accepté de c'est clair j'en ai je
voulais dire enfin c'est pas Philippe me
pardonnera je ne sous-estime pas du tout
la fille bon c'est pas exactement le
même enjeu c'est pas le même enjeu et je
pense qu'il n'aurait pas été je vous le
dis tel que je peins responsable de ma
part de refuser en disant ben ouais ah
non je suis à la fuite c'est quand même
moins exposé
c'est moins risqué je suis à la fuite
depuis trois mois
j'y reste circuler il y a rien à voir
bon oui
oui bien sûr j'ai compris exactement bon
mais pas encore une fois la RATP
représenté des enjeux de tête et qu'il
me paraissait difficile de ne pas
pouvoir
essayer d'y faire face voilà donc voilà
je comprends tout ce que vous me dites
mais il me semble encore une fois que
évidemment il faut essayer d'inscrire ça
dans la durée mais bon
la vie de ce passe pas toujours comme on
passe comme on l'a programme bon
question très importante qui reviennent
en plusieurs questions d'ailleurs
si Monsieur Pointreau sur leur fait sur
quel financement affecté au transport
aux autorités organisatrices et en
particulier à IDFM mobilité comment
est-ce qu'il faut augmenter quelques le
Pass Navigo même si tu es un montant là
pour le coup
je vais vous faire des observations
d'abord c'est pas à supposer que je le
devienne au président de la RATP de
décider ça c'est vraiment une décision
politique des instances compétentes
l'État pour le versement mobilité
IDFM mobilité pour le Pass Navigo et
donc j'ai été un état de prendre des
décisions je les ai assumé on était
d'accord pas d'accord je vais pas vous
bon mais j'ai bien compris je peux pas à
la fois dire j'ai quitté le chant de la
vie politique pour revenir sur un champ
managérial pour à nouveau me recyclerc
simplement ce que j'observe ce que j'ai
dit comme j'ai dit à l'Afrique nous
devrons de quelle nature à quelle
hauteur trouver des ressources
supplémentaires pour financer les
infrastructures de transport en France
toutes les données comparatives le
démontre dans les données comparatives
simplement par rapport aux ressources
propres un rapport puisque quelqu'un a
fait allusion de la Cour des comptes de
la Chambre des Comptes rappeler que le
financement des coûts d'exploitation et
transports en Île-de-France couverts par
les recettes en espèces le passmanium
était je crois de 26 27 25% par là hein
alors que dans d'autres pays en moyenne
il est beaucoup plus élevé
donné comparative mais je crois que le
Sénat bien entendu en a parfaitement
connaissant dernière élément ce que j'ai
dit aussi lorsque j'étais devant vous à
la fille c'est le rapporteur sec combien
je tiens à cette idée je pense que pour
que tout ça soit acceptable c'est-à-dire
qu'on est à la fois les moyens de
financer les infrastructure transport et
que ça ne pèse pas trop sur les
contribuables qui s'appelle les
entreprises qui s'appellent les usagers
etc il faut des paniers de recettes
faut des paniers de recettes et on voit
bien d'ailleurs que la crise énergétique
actuellement montre que lorsqu'on est
dépendant d'une seule source de
financement si celle-ci diminue bien
évidemment la politique publique
conduite se trouve menacée donc mon
opinion je le répète c'est qu'il faudra
accroître le panier de recettes un peu
de tout j'ai envie de dire nécessaire à
l'affectation des infrastructures et des
fonctionnements de nos systèmes de
transport collectif c'est absolument
indispensable on a devant nous monsieur
Pointreau parlait de l'entrée du Grand
Paris Express je n'ai pas évoqué grand
chantier
que j'ai bien connu à une des périodes à
laquelle vous faisiez référence
chantier formidable qui va alors là pour
le coup quasiment doublé quand il sera
terminé le nombre de lignes à la
disposition des voyageurs bon je
comprends très bien les inquiétudes
d'Île-de-France mobilité qui voit
arriver
l'écoute de de fonctionnement de cette
infrastructure et qui se dit ben je suis
face à un mur qui va falloir régler bon
donc
l'édition n'ont pas été prise vous
citiez janvier de 2020
et l'annonce faite par Édouard Philippe
alors Premier ministre il se trouve que
janvier 2020 c'est peu de temps avant
mars 2020 il y a eu une crise sanitaire
donc c'est vrai que ça n'a pas été un
moment propice à prendre ce type de
décision je rappelle quand même puisque
j'ai eu des questions tout à l'heure sur
toutes les AOM
que j'ai pris pendant la crise sanitaire
y compris et notamment pour
Île-de-France mobilité un certain nombre
de décisions
l'assurant leur survie et que le
Parlement d'ailleurs voté je me permets
de le rappeler au point même d'ailleurs
pour Île-de-France mobilité la Cour des
comptes en avait fait le reproche qu'on
a été presque au-delà de leurs besoins
puisque début 2022 où je sais plus quand
enfin au premier semestre 2022
Île-de-France mobilité à restituer
l'écart à l'état donc on les a pas
laissé tomber mais encore une fois je
conviens volontiers avec vous et je me
semble aussi me référer à ce que je vous
avais dit lors de la précédente audition
que il y a le problème structurel qui
reste à régler sur la finance
l'acceptation de financement
supplémentaire sur la qualité de l'air
c'est vrai que c'est une question qui
m'a été reposée et pour laquelle je n'ai
pas répondu donc là aussi
cette sachez-le un enjeu prioritaire
pour la pour la RATP depuis plusieurs
années il de France mobilité aussi si
j'ai bien compris à à voter
on va mis en place un plan d'action
pour volontaire enfin pour pour à la
fois surveiller la qualité de l'air
d'accord donc il y a un réseau
et RP je vous signale puisque chacun ici
connaît à Paris a conduit en juin
dernier une expertise à la demande
d'Île-de-France mobilité et qui a montré
que le dispositif de mesure mise en
œuvre par la RATP sur ce sujet est-elle
un des plus complets au monde et puis la
deuxième étude simplement que je voulais
vous signaler parce que là c'est un
organisme aussi que vous connaissez bien
qui est l'ancêtre et l'anceste a réalisé
une expertise qui a été publiée en juin
dernier
avec sur la définition de valeur guide
de l'air intérieur parce que justement
il n'y a pas de norme et cette expertise
constate une absence d'effets sanitaires
je cite lié à l'exposition des voyageurs
à la pollution de l'air dans les
enceintes ferroviaires souterraines en
l'état des connaissances scientifiques
actuelle bon et elle propose puisque
encore une fois il n'y en a pas des
valeurs indicatives non réglementaires
afin d'inciter tous les opérateurs à
accélérer les opérations d'amélioration
de la qualité de l'air je indique aussi
au Sénat si vous ne le savez pas qui a
des contentieux qui sont engagés
par des associations je crois à
l'endroit de la RATP donc c'est dire que
nous sommes mobilisés que c'est un sujet
qu'il faut prendre tout à fait au
sérieux dans les tout à l'heure je
parlais vous savez des investissements
vous l'avez peut-être entendu et
j'y suis pour rien je le dis avec
d'autant plus d'aisance dans les
nouveaux matériels roulant qui sont
commandés
la question de leurs émissions de
particulaire qui a un impact sur la
qualité de l'air est pris encore et
prise en considération de façon à ce que
on puisse avoir une action concrète en
la matière
je regarde après il y a beaucoup de
questions auxquelles j'avais déjà quand
même pas mal me semble-t-il répondu
dans l'exposé liminaire long que je fais
devant merci
certains d'entre vous m'ont fait part de
leur impératif de partir à 19h donc je
vous propose les trois dernières
questions pour que toutes celles et ceux
qui ont été présents puissent voter
parce que ce serait dommage de m'avoir
été présent jusque là Pinter d'arrêter à
18h55 je lui donne la parole à elle
rigole
merci monsieur le Président je suis
Premier ministre moi je vais commencer
mon propos par
vous dire que je vois votre nomination
votre potentiel nomination avec beaucoup
d'intérêt
la RATP c'est un opérateur mondial de
transport urbain qui a planté dans 4
continents et plus de 15 pays c'est
aussi un opérateur qui exploite au
quotidien plusieurs modes de transport
traditionnel on en a parlé le métro le
bus le tram mais aussi une nouvelle
mobilité en tant que partenaire sur les
navettes autonomes ou sur les parkings
intelligents connectés alors RATP est
fortement implanté principalement en
Île-de-France mais les déplacements de
demain s'ils doivent être innovants ne
seront pas seulement
urbains
alors très rapidement ce premier
ministre à la tête de la RATP
avez-vous comme défi à venir celui
d'être un acteur de la mobilité
accompagnant les déplacements innovants
aussi dans les zones qui ne sont pas
fortement urbanisés et pouvez-vous nous
indiquer un ou deux une ou deux pistes
que les RTT pourraient mettre en avant
au profit des territoires
si je vais donner la parole à tech oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vous l'avez dit en
introduction la RATP est un
des grands leader mondiaux sur le
transport urbain on a des enjeux
effectivement très très importants en
termes climatique du développement du
transport humain dans tous les grandes
mégalopoles mondiales je sais pas si
vous m'entendez bien si c'est bon
comment vous les voyez vous l'évolution
de ce rôle de la RATP à l'international
est-ce que c'est juste essayer de
prendre des parts de marché par rapport
à
d'autres
prestataires de même type même si vous
n'êtes pas extrêmement nombreux à
l'échelle mondiale ou est-ce que dans
cette logique de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre des des grands
systèmes
urbains mondiaux est-ce que demain la
RATP peut aussi venir avec des
investissements de développement avec
des investissements carbone et arriver
avec des projets qui soient des projets
plus intégrés
merci je vais donner la parole à
Frédéric marchand merci monsieur le
Président et merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour la déclinaison de cette
feuille de route que vous nous avez
faite intéressante moi je vais rebondir
effectivement sur les propos des rigoles
puisque quand on parle RATP on parle de
transport
la RATP a maintenant depuis plusieurs
années
comment dire défini tout un champ
d'expertise sur lesquels elle travaille
nouvelle mobilité télécommunications
immobiliers logistique urbaine gestion
d'énergie font aujourd'hui un peu partie
de la palette des savoir-faire intégrés
et complémentaires du groupe et en
janvier 2021 a été créé RATP solution
ville qui se veut être un apporteur de
solutions pour les collectifs des
collectivités donc au milieu de tous les
défis qui sont les vôtres je voulais
justement savoir pour reprendre un peu
les propos de mon collègue il rigole
quelle est la place que vous entendez
donner à ce cette apporteur de solutions
qui je pense pour les collectivités de
notre pays est très très important merci
merci chers collègues je vais donner
pour terminer
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre moi j'ai une
question très simple et qui est plutôt
une inquiétude dans vos propos vous avez
indiqué que vous souhaitiez recentrer
l'activité
et
ne plus considérer si j'ai bien traduit
mais je pense que j'ai bien compris
vos filiales et le développement à
l'international et ça me paraît être
dangereux pour les RATP parce que je
pense qu'une entreprise doit se
développer c'est un fleuron à
l'international sur de nombreux marchés
et puis pour pour conclure je dirais que
en tant que responsable de mon groupe je
n'ai pas donné et mon groupe n'a pas
donné une consigne de hotte chacun fait
comme toujours son âme et conscience et
que à titre personnel et ça n'est pas du
tout une question de compétence monsieur
le Premier ministre je ne voterai pas
pour votre nomination pour deux raisons
la première c'est que je l'ai déjà fait
il y a trois mois pour la fuite et la
seconde c'est que le message
envoyé ou la trace laissée par cette
démarche du président de la République
va je pense contribuer à éloigner encore
un peu plus nos concitoyens
alors on peut le traduire comme on veut
je peux faire de phrase
sur le sujet mais ou de petits mots mais
va contribuer à éloigner nos concitoyens
de la chose publique parce que on est
dans une défiance et le fait de
positionner les uns ou les autres comme
on le fait depuis quelques mois alors
que le Président de la République avait
déclaré qu'il devait qu'il voulait faire
autrement on parlait de l'ancien monde
on avait copains qui étaient recasés etc
moi j'ai pas vu de rupture à ce niveau
là je pense que les choses se sont même
accélérées donc et pour ces raisons à
titre personnel mais ça n'est pas du
tout vis-à-vis de vos compétences et de
vos qualités vous avez suscité vous avez
un capital à la fois de sympathie
participé par chacun d'entre nous et moi
le premier mais pour ces raisons je
enfin pour les autres raisons que j'ai
évoqué je ne vous accorderai pas mon
suffrage
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
10 minutes très bien merci beaucoup je
regrette
vous le dis hein oui oui mais je ne
crois pas enfreindre quelconque principe
oui pas moi mais en fait c'est moi qui
suis devant vous ce soir bon donc
par contre là où je veux clarifier un
point parce que là pour le coup c'est
moi qui me suis mal exprimé donc là là
c'est une question de fond
c'est pas que je n'oppose pas du tout je
pense je dis je n'ose pas du tout je
finis ma phrase le cœur de métier et les
activités de filiales pas du tout soit
clair d'accord je suis pas certain
d'avoir j'ai dit la priorité des
priorités c'est le cœur de métier
c'est-à-dire recentrer ou abandonner je
le précise bien simplement
vous parliez de la confiance de nos
concitoyens j'ai ici une assemblée de
gens très avertis il faut quand même que
je puisse dire roi si je suis patron de
la RATP écouter je vais conquérir le
métro de Sydney ça ça marche très bien
oui mais alors à Paris
on est d'accord oui mais voilà enfin
c'est c'est pas que c'est pas que des
mots quand même voyez bon donc
c'est par ces ça rejoint la question je
crois que c'est Monsieur Dantec qui a
posé en réalité
d'abord pourquoi il faut aller à
l'international sur nos bas c'est à dire
sur ce qu'on sait faire il faut être
cohérent c'est ça que je veux il faut
qu'il y ait une cohérence sur le fond et
sur le contenu entre politique du cœur
réacteur et la politique de
filialisation nos savoir-faire c'est la
ville c'est le développement durable
donc oui par exemple effectivement
on va exporter on a ce qu'on sait bien
faire et dans ce qu'on sait bien faire
il faut que nous soyons exemplaire en
termes de développement durable et
d'empreintes écologique et il faudrait
même que ce soit un plus pour assurer la
promotion de ce savoir-faire contenu du
contexte que vous connaissez tous
évidemment il faut savoir travailler sur
ce point j'ajoute je le répète quand
même s'il y a une ouverture à la
concurrence
ma réalité ça s'est passé
chronologiquement sans inverse on peut
pas dire on va conduire des parts de
marché en Europe Italie
dans le reste du monde et dire ben non
mais
chez nous évidemment mais personne ne
peut venir conquérir des parts de marché
sympa ça tient pas très longtemps la
route bon donc il faut avoir une vision
équilibrée et une vision quoi donc
monsieur mandeli vraiment je rectifie
mon propos s'il n'était pas clair
simplement je crois qu'il faut qu'on
soit cohérent que c'est voilà par
exemple on a acquis un savoir-faire sur
l'automatide les métros automatiques je
pense que là il faut qu'on se donne le
moyen de l'exporter encore davantage il
y a des enjeux évidemment industriels
l'autre marque de fabrique historique de
la RATP c'est la ville c'est là c'est le
rôle des transports dans la dans la
structuration du tissu urbain donc là on
a ça à faire et alors évidemment j'ai
beaucoup aimé les questions de Monsieur
marchand de Monsieur Gaulle qui touche
ma corde sans eBay est-ce que vous
viendriez pas par hasard aussi sur le
monde rural bon
bon alors
on m'indique sachez-le qu'en expérimente
des véhicules autonomes déjà pour les
appliquer à certaines zones qui seraient
susceptibles de rouler dans des zones
rurales bon
et puis ça reste un Île-de-France mais
c'est du côté de Saint-Rémy de
saint-rémy-lès-chevreux donc je dis
pourquoi pas mais bon pour l'instant
encore une fois le cœur du savoir-faire
de RATP il est dans les villes
urbanisées y compris d'ailleurs dans les
villes moyennes les grandes villes
moyennes de province actuellement plutôt
située du reste dans l'Ouest dans
l'ouest de la France
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre donc
on va passer au je vous rappelle que 1
il n'y a pas de délégation de vote 2
vous avez trois possibilités
et ce ne sont que ces mots qu'il faut
employer pour
contre
où vous laisser le bulletin blanc pour
contre au bulletin blanc voilà
je vais laisser la parole au rapporteur
qui va
vous appeler
et vous allez venir voter OUI